mr hancock thank you very much for
joining us um i'll talk to you about
partygate in just a minute but i know
that you are working today and talking
about um special educational needs and
disabilities helping children in schools
and um what you're implementing or
trying to talk
trying to implement today is the subject
of a long delayed review and now it's um
subject to 13 weeks consultation with
parents talk to me about what you're
doing and the criticism leveled at you
that there's still a lack of urgency in
this area
well it's not i don't think the
criticisms leveled me personally at this
time because i'm not in government what
i'm doing is campaigning for
people who are dyslexic like me or have
other special educational needs to make
sure that we get early identification
and then the support that people need
and that is absolutely at the core of
this paper that's been published today
um i think you know that to get this
published within six months of becoming
the secretary of state is shows how
committed nadim zahawi is to this agenda
um and it is a system that is long
overdue reform because identification
often comes far far too late and has
done four decades you know in my case at
university
and i hear that story over and over and
over again from people and we need to
make sure that identification is earlier
we also need to make sure the government
get the details right
and so i do think consultation is really
important in this area because the
details are so complicated there are so
dif so many different
forms of special educational need if you
like from
you know a whole spectrum um that making
sure that those details are right is
important i think if the po frankly if
the government had published this and
said we're not going to consult this is
the answer there would have been even
more of a hullabaloo about that so you
know the the the fact that the criticism
is over the timing of the consultation i
think demonstrates that people
support the direction of travel support
the work the government's trying to do
i'm really pleased with this paper it's
not the answer but it is the it's the
direction we need to go and it gives a
clear route map to reforming a system
that's long overdue reform yeah as you
said important to get the details right
in this area ms hancock thank you for
coming on today because um you will be
well aware that one of our top stories
is about those fixed penalty notices
handed out um to government staff
members for parties at downing street
and whitehall this is a clear sign
that the law was broken
well we haven't seen that yet from the
from the met police have we we haven't
heard the news of
of whether those have been issued we've
just been told that they will be the
look well they only issue the fixed
penalty notices if covered rules covered
laws were broken
well the
the pm has apologized and you know the
question that we've got that faces us
today
is do we want to change prime minister
in the middle of a war i haven't even
got the prime minister not only
a second i haven't even gotten to that
question yet i know i know that it's
coming though i know that it's coming no
i know but let's not pre-judge things
let's not pre-judge things i just want
to go through this because you know we
are going over old ground but what i'm
talking about is fixed penalty notices
are issued when a law has been broken
but what we're struggling with today is
that number 10 and nobody from the
conservatives will actually come out and
hold your hands up and go the met police
have found us guilty of breaking the law
why not well we haven't seen i haven't
seen that d because i haven't seen that
detail yet and the met haven't published
that they think they'll be issuing 20
people
but they haven't given any detail i'm
certainly not privy to it um but the
number 10 uh team have said that if the
prime minister is issued with such a
notice then uh then they will make that
public okay then he will have been found
to break the law is that correct
well
the thing is that you know this this
issue has been gone over a huge amount i
understand of course i understand
the
the concern the frustration and the
emotions that people have when
when faced with these this sort of um
allegations
then if a fixed penalty notice is issued
yeah that is an indication of breaking
the law so if the prime minister gets
one of those he has break on the law is
that correct
well it depends what happens but the
real question okay is do what where do
we go from here and the prime minister
has apologized
he understands and i certainly
understand
the
the the the anger and frustration that
people
feel about this issue but the real
question that we've got and this is why
i address this you know my first
response to your question the real
question we've got is what do we do
about it now okay and what we do about
it now is we need to move forward
thankfully we're one of the first
countries in the world out of covert
restrictions in large part down to the
uh speed of the vaccination rollout
which we delivered here
than any other i get that but the
question is you're saying down to the
pm's judgment yeah again what happens
now i mean it's almost like you're
glossing over it in terms of if the
prime minister is found to have broken
the law and you know those people at
downing downing street parties and white
hole parties have been found to break
the law otherwise they wouldn't be
issued with fixed penalty notices if
laws have been broken and if the prime
minister misled parliament by saying and
i quote here back in december to secure
stamina um their uh all guidance was
completely followed in number 10 he
repeatedly assured the house there were
no parties so if he misled parliament
lying in the words of labour are we just
to pretend there are no consequences to
those actions
and we just move on
the prime minister's the prime
minister's apologize but but it is
really important you know when you're as
as an mp as a representative of my
constituents
you know if
once the prime minister has apologized
the idea that you should
that he should have to resign
following something like this
that question has to take into account
everything that's going on
because this isn't the only subject it
is an important subject of course it is
and we've just been talking about
another important subject and then
there's some huge subjects facing the
country like the war and then there's
the economic uh situation as well do you
get that
that will really upset people watching
because yes of course there are other
things going on but to those people we
saw at that memorial in central london
today at the memorial um wall opposite
where you're standing now you can see it
from the house of parliament to those
people it really does matter and you
know in their eyes if the prime minister
broke the law and lied he should face
consequences and apology doesn't cut it
you can't just confuse it with the war
in ukraine the brexit issue you can't
confuse it
i'm not confusing anything i'm being
really clear which is that
the question of who should be prime
minister has to take everything into
account and he has apologized for this
he's made changes in the number 10
operation but you've got to ask the
question
do we want to change prime minister now
no
who do we want to be leading the country
when
when the when boris johnson is not only
providing leadership to this country
frankly he's providing leadership
with with colleagues and friends and
allies around the world in tackling the
threat of vladimir putin which is a
threat to us all it's not just a threat
to ukraine but it's a threat that
undermines the the the
the safe liberal world order that we've
been living in um and so there are
huge questions
about uh
about how we keep ourselves safe in the
years ahead you know and problems that
we thought frankly i thought had gone
away i i didn't think we'd have war in
europe in my lifetime i thought that was
a 20th century thing not a 21st century
thing um and we have to address these
questions as well so i think the i i
think given that the prime minister has
apologized it is important to look
forward
okay matt hancock former health
secretary thank you for speaking to us
here today on sky news reacting to the
news that the metropolitan police are
issuing up to 20 fixed penalty notices
for parties held at downing street and
whitehall